I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. For score and seven years ago, our fathers brought forth on this continent a new nation, conceived in liberty and dedicated to the proposition that all men are created equal. LITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLIT Andy is struggling to inspire his employees. He decides to take them on a corporate retreat to the Gettysburg Museum.
我是珍妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，并且是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了最棒的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当时在场的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。八十七年前，我们的先辈们在这片大陆上建立了一个新国家，它孕育于自由之中，并奉行“人生而平等”这一真理。LITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLITLIT安迪正努力激励他的员工。他决定带他们去葛底斯堡博物馆进行一次公司团建。
He even has custom hats made. The employees who choose to stay at the office are recruited by Robert California to brainstorm innovative game changers and guess who gets Robert's attention? Kevin! Kevin the Cookie Man. Yeah. Much to Ryan's family. of game changers and guess who gets Robert's attention? Kevin!
他还特意定制了帽子。选择留在办公室的员工则被罗伯特·加利福尼亚招募，来头脑风暴出具有创新性的颠覆性点子，你猜谁引起了罗伯特的注意？凯文！饼干人凯文。没错。让瑞恩大失所望的是……颠覆性的点子，你猜谁引起了罗伯特的注意？凯文！
Kevin the cookie man. Yeah. Much to Ryan's dismay. I know, he's just going to have to be the hot guy now. Fast fact number one, this is a location breakdown. Fan question from Elise W. Ingette'sburg, Pennsylvania. I love that. Elise says, I have been waiting since the start of this podcast to write in about this episode
饼干人凯文。没错。这让瑞恩大失所望。我知道，他现在不得不成为性感型男了。第一条趣味事实，这是一个外景解析。来自伊莉斯·W的粉丝提问。发自宾夕法尼亚州葛底斯堡。我太喜欢这个了。伊莉斯说，我从这个播客开播起就一直等着写信来聊聊这一集，
because I grew up in Gettysburg, Pennsylvania and this little town was absolutely tickled that we were chosen to be featured in this amazing sitcom. I know I can speak for the town when I say we were honored. Elise goes on to say, it is obvious that the scenes located in Gettysburg were not actually filmed there. Oh Elise, I'm so sorry. I would love to hear a location breakdown. I would also love to know if anyone from the Castor crew came to Gettysburg or if you were able to get donations from local businesses or tour our historic town.
因为我在宾夕法尼亚州葛底斯堡长大，我们这个小镇对于能被选中在这部精彩的情景喜剧中出镜感到无比兴奋。我知道我可以代表全镇人民说，我们深感荣幸。伊莉斯接着说，很明显，剧里那些设定在葛底斯堡的场景并不是真的在那里拍摄的。哦，伊莉斯，我太遗憾了。我很想听听外景解析。我还想知道是否剧组有任何人来过葛底斯堡，或者你们是否向当地商家寻求过赞助，还是参观了我们这座历史名城。
Please, ladies, add the Gettysburg National Battlefield to your list of tourists to take. It is a beautiful area with an amazing history and wonderful people that all, including myself, would love to show you around. I'm adding it to our list. Our list is getting really long. It's going to require a lot of travel. But I'm really looking forward to the season of my life where I am just kind of an older gal that gets to like go to fun places of my life where I am just kind of an older gal that gets
求求了，女士们，把葛底斯堡国家战场加入你们的旅游打卡清单吧。这是一个美丽的地方，有着惊人的历史和热情的人们，包括我在内，大家都会很乐意带你们到处转转。我把它加入我们的清单了。我们的清单越来越长了。这需要大量的旅行。但我真的很期待我人生中的那个阶段，那时我差不多就是一个老太太，可以去一些有趣的地方……人生中的那个阶段，那时我差不多就是一个老太太，可以去……
to like go to fun places with my best friend. You're literally describing my mom and dad. That is what they do. They travel around to different places in the United States and abroad. Little nuggets. Not the big hits. They go to the little charming places. Yeah, they're always finding some little nuggets somewhere.
去和我的好朋友一起去好玩的地方。你简直是在形容我爸妈。他们就是这么干的。他们去美国各地和海外的不同地方旅行。寻找小惊喜。而不是那些大热门。他们去那些迷人的小地方。对，他们总能在某处找到一些小惊喜。
Well, at least we shot the Gettysburg scenes at Woodley Park in Van Aes. The museum and archives were sets that we built on our warehouse stages. Our design team did a lot of research to try and make the park look like the real Gettysburg. For example, Pam Punch, who was our NBC executive grew up around Gettysburg and said, hey, Punch, who was our NBC executive grew up around Gettysburg
好吧，其实我们在范奈斯的伍德利公园拍摄了葛底斯堡的场景。博物馆和档案馆是我们在仓库摄影棚里搭建的布景。我们的设计团队做了大量的研究，努力让这个公园看起来像真正的葛底斯堡。例如，我们的NBC高管潘·潘奇就是在葛底斯堡附近长大的，她说……我们的NBC高管潘·潘奇就是在葛底斯堡附近长大的，
and said, hey, it looks pretty good. She gave some notes. Our art department brought in the cannons. They brought in the signage and other kind of decorations to look like Gettysburg. And Phil Shea got a bunch of stuff from the actual Gettysburg battlefield national park gift store. Well, I reached out to Michael Gallenberg. You guys have heard us talk about him before. He was our production designer. And I wanted to know if he had any stories about putting this episode together. He emailed me back right away.
并且说，嘿，看起来挺不错的。她提出了一些意见。我们的美术部门运来了大炮。他们运来了标牌和其他各种装饰，让这里看起来像葛底斯堡。菲尔·谢伊还从真正的葛底斯堡国家军事公园礼品店里弄来了一堆东西。好吧，我联系了迈克尔·加伦伯格。你们以前听过我们谈论他。他是我们的美术指导，我想知道他有没有关于筹备这一集的任何故事。他立刻回了我的邮件。
And he said, you know, Angela Gettysburg was the end of my tenure on the office. Wow. He said, in fact, it might have been my last official episode. So Michael actually put me in touch with Matt Flynn from the design team, and he had such fun things to share about this episode. Ooh, like what?
他说，你知道的，安吉拉，葛底斯堡是我在《办公室》任职的尾声。哇。他说，事实上，这很可能是我的最后官方一集。所以迈克尔实际上让我和设计团队的马特·弗林取得了联系，他对这一集有那么多有趣的事情要分享。哦？比如呢？
OK, first of all, he says greetings to you both, Jen and Angela, and congratulations on your very popular podcast. Yay! So sweet. Yes. Great way to start an email this. And then he went on to say, yes,
好吧，首先，他说向你们俩，珍和安吉拉问好，并祝贺你们的播客大受欢迎。耶！太贴心了。对。以这个作为邮件的开头太棒了。然后他接着说，是的，
indeed, this episode was my first stint as production designer at the office. However, he had been working with Michael Gallenberg as art director since season two. Okay. I remember him. Yeah. He knew the show very well. He shared one of the demands of the script was to provide a ready for this. Here was his call to action. We need you to provide for us a verdant setting which has a parking lot adjacent to a plaza-like area in front of an existing structure where we could then turn it into a Gettysburg Visitor Center. Wow! So Jenna, you mentioned there were cannons, right? Yeah. You said they did a lot of research. They wanted to place them the way they were in the actual park. And they had to rent these cannons from a prop house.
确实如此，这一集是我在《办公室》担任美术指导的第一次亮相。不过，他从第二季开始就一直和美术指导迈克尔·加伦伯格一起工作。好的。我记得他。是的。他对这部剧非常了解。他分享了剧本的要求之一是提供一个——准备好了吗？这就是他的任务召唤。我们需要你为我们提供一个葱郁的环境，这里要有一个停车场，停车场旁边是一个类似广场的区域，正对着一栋现成的建筑，然后我们可以把它变成葛底斯堡游客中心。哇！所以珍妮娜，你提到过那里有大炮，对吧？是的。你说他们做了很多研究。他们想把大炮摆放在它们在实际公园里的位置。而且他们必须从道具租赁公司租这些大炮。
Crazy. Listen to this. He said when they went to rent them, some of the cannons were in a distressed state and they required cosmetic repair. Because the prop house said, you know, these were used and gone with the wind. What? Yes. He went on to say that the Prop. Rental House had a historic inventory. Now, you can't always 100% be accurate about where they were used and everything.
太疯狂了。听听这个。他说当他们去租这些大炮时，其中一些大炮处于破损状态，需要进行外观修复。因为道具公司说，你知道的，这些曾在《乱世佳人》里使用过。什么？是的。他接着说，道具租赁公司拥有历史库存。现在，你不可能百分之百确定它们在哪里被使用过以及所有细节。
But apparently, the lore of these cannons were that they were the same ones used and the movie gone with the wind. Wow, they kept those a long time. He also said one of the things he remembers is the existing structure that they made to look like the Gettysburg Visitor Center was actually a public restroom. I wondered.
但显然，关于这些大炮的传说，它们就是电影《乱世佳人》中使用的同一批大炮。哇，他们保存了这么久。他还说，他记得的一件事是，他们用来假装成葛底斯堡游客中心的那个现成建筑，实际上是一个公共厕所。我就觉得。
I have to be honest with you. It had restroom qualities. Did it really? Yes. When I saw it in the episode, I thought, is that a bathroom? He said that you know, covered it. And then right as you enter,
老实说。它有着公厕的特质。真的吗？是的。当我在剧集里看到它时，我想，那是个厕所吗？他说你知道的，他们把它遮盖起来了。然后就在你刚进去的地方，
they built sort of like a fake wall, but if you went just around the corner, there was a row of toilets. That is so funny, because you know, Angela, you and I weren't there. We stay back at the office. Yeah. So I love all that detail.
他们建了一堵类似假墙的东西，但如果你绕过那个拐角，就会发现有一排马桶。太搞笑了，因为你知道的，安吉拉，你和我都当时不在场。我们留在办公室了。对。所以我喜欢所有这些细节。
I did find in an early draft that we were sent of the table read that my character went. You went? Yeah. What did you do the whole time? I don't know. I'm miserable. Yes, but I guess someone changed their mind
我在我们拿到的一份早期的剧本围读初稿中发现，我的角色去了。你去了？对。你全程都在干什么？我不知道。我很痛苦。是的，但我想有人改变了主意，
and I'm so glad. Because it meant, A, I got to be with you and I got to be in an air conditioned room for the whole week because it was hot. Well, I loved that. I'm so glad he got back with you. Thank you, Matt. I know. Well, fast back number two, I thought we could use a teeny tiny history lesson on the Battle of
我太高兴了。因为这意味着，第一，我可以和你在一起，第二，我可以在一个有空调的房间里待上一整周，因为当时天气很热。嗯，我喜欢这样。我很高兴他把你弄回去了。谢谢你，马特。我知道。好吧，第二条趣味事实，我想我们可以上一堂关于……的微型历史课。
Gettysburg. Okay. That was fought July 1st through 3rd, 1863. You know, just because we're there in the episode. All right, Professor Fisher. Continue. Here it is. The Battle of Gettysburg was led by Union Army General George Mead, and this is the battle that ended the Civil War. The Gettysburg National Cemetery and Gettysburg National Military Park are maintained by the U.S. National Park Service, and four months after this battle is when President Abraham Lincoln delivered the famous Gettysburg address. So you know the one that begins the four score and seven years ago. And that address also contains the famous line quote government of the people by the people for the people.
葛底斯堡战役。好的。那是1863年7月1日至3日打响的。你知道的，因为我们在剧集里正好身处那里。好吧，费舍尔教授。请继续。就是这样。葛底斯堡战役由联邦军将军乔治·米德领导，这就是结束了内战的那场战役。葛底斯堡国家公墓和葛底斯堡国家军事公园由美国国家公园管理局维护，在这场战役四个月后，亚伯拉罕·林肯总统发表了著名的《葛底斯堡演说》。所以你知道那个以“八十七年前”开头的演讲。而且那次演讲还包含了那句名言：“民有、民治、民享的政府”。
Gettysburg is located in Adams County, Pennsylvania and it's about two hours and 45 minutes away from Scranton. So they would have had time to watch limitless. Oh, well, I've got a whole lot to say about this time on the bus. I'm glad you're okay. But basically, yes, Andy made everyone spend six hours round trip on that bus that day. Angela, for when we go visit the Gettysburg National Military Park, it is open year round.
葛底斯堡位于宾夕法尼亚州的亚当斯县，距离斯克兰顿大约两小时四十五分钟的车程。所以他们会有时间看《永无止境》。哦，好吧，关于在车上的这段时间，我有太多话要说了。我很高兴你没事。但基本上，是的，安迪那天让每个人在那辆大巴上往返花了六个小时。安吉拉，当我们去参观葛底斯堡国家军事公园时，它是全年开放的。
And you can tour the park by walking. You can drive your car. They have like audio tours, then you can download on an app. You can do it by bus or horse. Please tell me horse. Yes, yes, lady. We have to do it by horse.
你可以通过步行游览公园。你可以开着车去。他们有那种可以在应用程序上下载的语音导览。你可以坐大巴或骑马游览。请告诉我我们要骑马。好的，好的，女士。我们必须骑马游览。
A hundred percent. Oh my gosh. That just moved up higher on my list. Yeah, mm-hmm. If you contour it by horse. Yes, it gets priority billy Yeah, so there you go. That's a little bit about Gettysburg Fastback number three is a crazy Weird thing that Steve Burgess told me happened while we were shooting this episode and you wouldn't tell me you said I'm gonna surprise you on the podcast, so what? I have photos.
百分之百。哦天哪。这在我的清单上排名又上升了。对，嗯哼。如果你能骑马游览。是的，这享有优先权，比利。好吧，就是这样。这就是关于葛底斯堡的一些内容。第三条趣味事实是一件疯狂而诡异的事情，史蒂夫·伯吉斯告诉我，我们在拍摄这一集时发生了这件事，而且你之前不肯告诉我，你说“我要在播客里给你一个惊喜”，所以是什么？我有照片。
What? Meredith's van was struck by lightning. What? In our parking lot. And it caught on fire. No way. Yeah. Just Kate, know that?
什么？梅雷迪思的面包车被闪电击中了。什么？就在我们的停车场里。而且它着火了。绝不可能。真的。凯特知道这事吗？
I don't know. We have to tell her. Yeah, the photos like a burned out shell of a van. Holy crap. He said they repaired it. I thought it looks like a goner to me, but they repaired it. I mean, it was a pretty junky looking van. So maybe it having a little lightning, distressing, wasn't the worst thing? No, there's like a giant fire hole. Oh my god. And a whole top of the car. In fire holes. Fire holes.
我不知道。我们得告诉她。对，照片就像是一个面包车被烧毁的空壳。真他妈的。他说他们把它修好了。我觉得它在我看来已经彻底报废了，但他们修好了。我的意思是，那本来就是一辆看起来挺破烂的面包车。所以也许经历了一点雷击带来的“沧桑感”，并不是最坏的事情？不，那上面有个巨大的火洞。哦天哪。还有车顶整个都没了。都是火洞。火洞。
They have a fire hole. I think that's what the, I think that's the technical term for. Come on. Getting it known out. But he said that our crew was actually at the technical Emmys. Remember the technical Emmys? Yeah.
它们有个火洞。我想那是，我想那是专业术语。别逗了。彻底报废了。但他说我们的剧组当时正在参加技术艾美奖。还记得技术艾美奖吗？对。
So much fun we have. So the technical Emmys are the weekend before the Emmys. And it's where they give Emmys to all of the crew members, editing, sound design, sort of all of those things. And so our crew was attending the Emmys when they got a phone call that Maris Mann was on fire. That is so crazy. There was so much crap in that van, that they just left in there like set decorating,
我们玩得太开心了。所以技术艾美奖是在艾美奖颁奖典礼前的那个周末。那是他们将艾美奖颁给所有剧组成员、剪辑、音效设计以及所有这些幕后人员的时候。所以我们的剧组当时正在参加艾美奖，这时他们接到一个电话，说梅雷迪思的面包车着火了。太疯狂了。那辆面包车里有太多的破烂，他们就随手扔在里面，像是布景装饰，
but it was like merit as a mess. I mean, what did the fire department think when they came to put that thing out? Oh my gosh. Yep. That is amazing. I will be sharing those pictures. You have to send them to me. I absolutely will.
但看起来就像梅雷迪思一样一团糟。我的天，消防队员赶来把火扑灭时是怎么想的？哦天哪。太神奇了。我会把那些照片分享出来的。你得发给我。我绝对会发。
Well, that's all I got for fast facts. I loved your fast facts. And you know what? Let's take a break, and when we come back, Gabe is holding a real boring meeting in the conference room. We're back, and we're in the conference room. Gabe is leading a meeting. He is outlining Saber's code of conduct and it's super boring. If there's an award for fake yawn acting, I think I should receive it because at 11
好吧，这就是我所有的趣味事实了。我很喜欢你的趣味事实。你知道吗？我们休息一下，等我们回来后，加比正在会议室里开一场极其无聊的会。我们回来了，我们现在在会议室里。加比正在主持会议。他正在概述萨博的行为准则，这超级无聊。如果有一个假打哈欠演技奖，我想我应该得奖，因为在第11
seconds I do a real great fake yawn. Wow. Mm-hmm. But yeah, Kelly says, oh my God, kill me. And Andy's like, hey, all right, obviously we all want to die, but we have to get through this. So Gabe, go ahead. It's okay.
秒时，我打了一个非常棒的假哈欠。哇。嗯哼。但是，凯莉说：“哦天哪，杀了我吧。”安迪则说：“嘿，行了，很明显我们都想死，但我们必须挺过去。所以加比，你继续吧。没关系。”
This is when Pam says, oh, I'm going into labor, which I guess she's been doing a lot. A lot! To get out of things. So no one believes her. No. They're like, you are not going into labor. But then, oh my gosh, her water breaks. She really is going into labor. And people are like, oh my gosh, okay. Well, I mean, good luck. We love you. And then a water bottle falls out from between her legs.
这时候潘说：“哦，我要生了。”我猜她最近经常用这招。经常！为了逃避事情。所以没有人相信她。没有。他们会说：“你才没有要生呢。”但接着，天哪，她的羊水破了。她真的是要生了。大家就说：“哦天哪，好吧。那个，祝你好运。我们爱你。”然后一个水瓶从她两腿之间掉了下来。
It's been duct tape to her thigh. Mm-hmm. Yeah, let me tell you about that. Why? Let me tell you how we did this. This was really tricky because I had to, and you can see me start to do it, I had that bottle duct taped to my thigh for real. It was just some leggings, right? And then I had to, like kinda undo the lid to let the water out. How did you do that?
它一直用胶带粘在她的腿上。嗯哼。是的，让我来告诉你这是怎么回事。为什么？让我告诉你我们是怎么拍的。这真的很棘手，因为我不得不——你可以看到我开始这么做了——我真的把那个瓶子用胶带粘在我的大腿上。就是穿了条打底裤，对吧？然后我不得不，有点像解开瓶盖把水放出来。你是怎么做到的？
I saw you see me start to do it. I kind of start to reach up and then the puddle. But then I had to also make the water bottle fall on the ground. So there's a cut because then as I'm shuffling out, we had to take the tape off. There was no way to make it fall off. So we kind of took the tape off and then I'm just shuffling with this bottle and like holding it with my thighs until I'm supposed to kind of
我看到你发现我开始这么做了。我有点把手伸上去，然后水坑就出现了。但随后我还得让水瓶掉到地上。所以这里有一个剪辑，因为当我踉踉跄跄走出去时，我们必须把胶带撕下来。根本没有办法让它自己掉下来。所以我们差不多把胶带撕了下来，然后我拿着这个瓶子踉踉跄跄地走，用大腿夹着它，直到我应该把它……
let it go onto the ground. Gosh. It was a whole like we spent, we're like, wait, how are we doing this? How is this tape suddenly falling off? I had this to my fake award show. Thank you. Fake yawning and then you get the award for stunt water bottle acting. I would love to see that on a plaque. stunt water bottle acting goes to
把它放到地上。天哪。这整个过程就像是——我们在想，等一下，我们到底该怎么拍？这胶带是怎么突然掉下来的？我有这个假颁奖典礼。谢谢。假打哈欠奖归我，然后你获得特技水瓶演技奖。我很希望能把这个刻在牌匾上。特技水瓶演技奖得主是……
fake or the other nominees. Fake yarn goes to. But that was how we did it. You did a great job. I had a lot of questions for Pam. I looked up to do people fake labor to get out of things and turns out people do. I don't doubt it.
假打哈欠，或者其他提名者。假打哈欠得主是……但我们就是这样拍的。你做得太棒了。我对潘有很多疑问。我特意去查了查现实中是不是有人通过假装临产来逃避事情，结果发现还真有。我不怀疑。
I think Pam just did it the most though. The episode is gonna start with Andy Onus phone. He's loudly saying that he cannot believe what he's hearing another client has been stolen. It's like war out there. No one's listening. Yes, he's trying to create a metaphor, such that everyone will go to Gettysburg with him basically.
不过我觉得潘只是用得最多罢了。这一集的开场是安迪在接电话。他大声说他简直不敢相信自己听到的消息，又有一个客户被抢了。外面简直就像战场。没人听指挥。是的，他试图创造一个隐喻，好让所有人基本上都跟他一起去葛底斯堡。
He holds up a pamphlet, a two minutes and twenty seconds. Phil Sheh made that pamphlet. Well done, Phil Sheh. Yes. But yeah, Andy's trying to rally the troops. What's that saying? Nothing brings people together like a common enemy. Yes.
他举起了一份宣传册，两分二十秒。那是菲尔·谢伊做的宣传册。干得漂亮，菲尔·谢伊。是的。不过安迪在试图鼓舞士气。那句话怎么说来着？没有什么比共同的敌人更能把人们凝聚在一起了。是的。
But Andy's trying to get a buzz going. He is. Dwight is gonna point out, he has a beef. Which is that everybody always talks about Gettysburg. Yeah. But nobody talks about the battle of shrewp farms. Which was actually home of the northernmost Battle of the Civil War. Askers like, no, it wasn't.
但安迪正试图掀起一阵热潮。确实如此。德怀特指出，他有一个心结。那就是每个人都在谈论葛底斯堡。对。但没有人谈论舒鲁普农场战役。那其实是内战最北端战役的发源地。问他的人说：“不，才不是。”
We had a fan catch from Melissa D who said, in drug testing in season two, Dwight says that his great grandfather's name was Dwight Shrewd. So considering the timeline, wouldn't this have been the Battle of Shrewd Farms? Yes! That is such a good catch. I love that. Oh, I wish you would have said that. There would have been such a cool callback. Yeah. We also had a fan question from Roar in Oxford, UK, who said, did you know there is a song that was released in 2018 called Battle of Shrewd Farms? It is by Lost in the City. There a banned from Kansas City, Missouri, led by songwriter and vocalist Shane Radford
我们收到了来自梅丽莎·D的粉丝粉丝互动，她说，在第二季的药检那一集里，德怀特说他曾祖父的名字叫德怀特·舒鲁普。所以考虑到时间线，这难道不应该是舒鲁普农场战役吗？没错！这个细节抓得太好了。我太喜欢了。哦，我真希望当时能说出这句话。那绝对是一个超酷的呼应。对。我们还收到了来自英国牛津的罗尔的粉丝提问，他说，你知道有一首2018年发行的歌曲叫《舒鲁普农场战役》吗？它是由Lost in the City演唱的。他们是来自密苏里州堪萨斯城的乐队，由词曲作者兼主唱肖恩·雷德福领衔，
with Cullen Wiley, Dustin Proctor and Kyle Constant. I found the song. There don't seem to be any lyrics that specifically say Battle of Shrute Farms. But that is the title of the song. I thought we could hear it. Okay let's do it! I'm It's a pretty good song. I have to say Dwight would have loved to rock out to that song. I think if you're making an office playlist, this would be a pretty cool addition. Rock and roll baby. Maybe kind of like super in the know. Well, here is a breakdown of who's going to go with Andy.
成员还有卡伦·威利、达斯汀·普罗クター和凯尔·康斯坦特。我找到了这首歌。歌词中似乎没有任何专门提到“舒鲁普农场战役”的地方。但这就是歌名的名字。我想我们可以听听看。好的，我们来听吧！这首歌挺不错的。我必须说，德怀特一定会喜欢跟着这首歌摇滚的。我想如果你在制作一张《办公室》的播放列表，这会是一个相当酷的补充。摇滚宝贝。也许有点那种行家里门的感觉。好吧，以下是跟安迪一起去的人员名单。
Oscar Dwight, Phyllis Aaron Stanley, and Jim. I was very surprised that Jim would be going. Well, so is Becca S from Rochester, Minnesota, who says why would Jim go to Gettysburg, a trip that is two and a half hours away, and leave Pam when she is nine months pregnant? Yeah, what's going on? I did find a deleted scene where Jim has a talking head about going to Gettysburg.
奥斯卡、德怀特、菲利斯、艾琳、斯坦利和吉姆。我很惊讶吉姆会去。好吧，罗彻斯特的贝卡·S也是这么想的，她说为什么吉姆要去葛底斯堡这样一个来回要两个半小时的旅行，而在潘怀孕九个月的时候抛下她不管？对，这到底是怎么回事？我确实找到了一段被删掉的片段，里面吉姆有一个关于去葛底斯堡的单人访谈。
Okay. I wanted us to hear it because once again, it's a window into Jim's childhood and pranking. I'm excited. I've actually never been to Gettysburg. My family was going to go once, but then my brothers convinced me that it was full of dead soldiers zombies. So I freaked out and we turned the car around. But I'm older now. I can outrun a zombie. Okay.
好的。我希望我们能听听看，因为这又一次成为了窥探吉姆童年和恶作剧的一扇窗户。我很兴奋。我其实从来没去过葛底斯堡。我家人本来打算去一次的，但后来我哥哥们说服我，说那里到处都是死士兵僵尸。所以我吓坏了，我们把车调头开走了。不过我现在长大了。我跑得比僵尸快。好吧。
But you know, I'm always like, why does Jim prank so much? Why does he prank so much? Look at his brothers. Yeah. Well, when we met his brothers, right? Yes. You're right. Jim's pranking origin story explained again. Once again. Yeah. Well, as the group is getting on to the bus, Andy's going to give all of them very
但你知道，我总是忍不住想，为什么吉姆那么喜欢搞恶作剧？他为什么这么爱恶作剧？看看他的兄弟们就知道了。对啊。对，当我们遇到他的兄弟们的时候，对吧？没错。吉姆恶作剧的起源故事再次得到了解释。又一次。是的。好吧，当大家上大巴时，安迪给每个人发了非常……
neon pink hats that read DM goes to G B. Yeah. And once they're on the bus, they have a big discussion about what they're going to do on the way there and they decide to watch Limitless. This is Darryl's suggestion, he brought it. Yeah. Guess what I did. What? I watched Limitless. Guess what I did. What? I watched every trailer I could find on Limitless,
荧光粉的帽子，上面写着DM前往GB。对。一旦他们上了大巴，他们就大声讨论在路上要做什么，并决定看《永无止境》。这是达里尔的建议，是他带来的。对。你猜我做了什么。什么？我看了《永无止境》。你猜我做了什么。什么？我看了所有能找到的关于《永无止境》的预告片，
so without watching the movie. But this was back in the day where a trailer basically says the whole movie and I watched like eight trailers. Jenna, I feel like I have a good handle on the movie. Well, I loved it. It's Bradley Cooper. Yeah, it's so good. You know, I have to ice my broken shoulder a lot in a day.
所以其实并没有看这部电影。但这可是当年的年代，当时的预告片基本上就把整部电影都剧透了，我大概看了八个预告片。珍妮娜，我觉得我对这部电影已经了如指掌了。好吧，我太喜欢了。那是布莱德利·库珀主演的。对，太棒了。你知道的，我一天里经常得给我受伤的肩膀冰敷。
And so what I've started doing is putting on a movie and icing and then I watch it throughout a whole day. That's how I watched Limitless. It's great. I wrote a note here. I said, now I wish I'd seen the whole movie should this be on our office ladies movie list. I think it should.
所以我开始做的事情就是放一部电影，然后一边冰敷，然后我一整天都在断断续续地看。我就是这样看完《永无止境》的。太棒了。我在这里写了一条笔记。我说，现在我真希望我当时看了整部电影，这应该加入我们的办公室女郎电影清单吗？我觉得应该。
Bradley Cooper plays it down and outwriter, and he gets this bootleg experimental drug from his ex brother-in-law or something. And then it makes it so that his brain is super clear, that idea that you only use 5% of your brain power. Now he has 100% 100% and then you see what he does with it. It got a 69% on run tomatoes, but it's only an hour and 45 minutes.
布莱德利·库珀饰演一个走投无路的作家，他从前小舅子那里弄到了一种非法的实验性药物。然后这让他的大脑变得超级清醒，就是那种“人类只开发了5%大脑潜能”的观点。现在他拥有100%了，然后你就看到了他用这100%做了什么。它在烂番茄上获得了69%的好评率，但片长只有一小时四十五分钟。
So they are still gonna have an hour to kill on this trip. So when they get to Gettysburg and they're all still watching the movie, eh eh. No, it doesn't track. Back in the office, it really feels like a vacation day. Meredith is napping with her, skirt open with her hand on it, I don't know.
所以他们在这次旅程中依然还有一个小时要打发。因此，当他们到达葛底斯堡，大家却还在看这部电影时，呃呃。不对，这逻辑不对。回到办公室，这感觉真的像是在放假。梅雷迪思在打瞌睡，裙子敞开着，手搭在上面，我不知道。
Like, yes, at five minutes and 17 seconds, she has a neck pillow, all of that. I wanted to know if that was scripted. Was it? It was. All of the business that we open on was scripted, and here's what it says. Stanley is playing cards with Kathy. Ryan sits at reception and Kelly sits on his lap, surfing the net.
就像是，对，在五分17秒时，她戴着一个颈枕，诸如此类。我想知道这是否是剧本里写好的。是吗？是的。我们开场时所有的这些群戏都是剧本写好的，上面是这样写的：斯坦利在和凯茜打牌。瑞恩坐在接待处，凯莉坐在他腿上上网。
Meredith sleeps with a neck pillow that says Southwest Airlines. Her skirt fly is unbuttoned like a man's pants. Kevin is looking over Pam's shoulder at a William Sonoma catalog. They are both very excited about whatever it is they're looking at. Angela makes copies and shoots dirty looks at people. That tracks. Yes. So now Robert California is going to walk in on this scene.
梅雷迪思戴着一个写着“西南航空”字样的颈枕打瞌睡。她的裙子拉链没系好，像个男人的裤子。凯文越过潘的肩膀看着一本威廉·索诺玛的目录。他们对正在看的东西都非常兴奋。安吉拉在复印文件，并向周围人投去嫌弃的目光。这很符合她的风格。是的。所以现在罗伯特·加利福尼亚将走进这个场景。
Yeah. And he is surprised to see that number one, not everyone is there. And number two, it seems like no one is working. Yeah. That's when Kelly is gonna tell him that Andy took some of the employees on a corporate retreat to Gettysburg. And Robert California says, well, you know, he was hoping to discuss some ideas with Andy, but maybe it's even better to discuss them with this group because they're the free thinkers. They didn't go.
对。他很惊讶地看到，第一，并不是所有都在这里。第二，似乎没有人工作。呀。就在这时，凯莉告诉他，安迪带着一些员工去葛底斯堡进行公司团建了。罗伯特·加利福尼亚说，好吧，你知道的，他原本希望能和安迪讨论一些想法，但也许和这群人讨论更好，因为他们是自由思想者。他们没有去。
Yes, they're the people who stayed. So he says, I want you all to brainstorm innovative game changers. Yeah, don't be afraid to get a little weird with it. And then he yells to wake up Meredith before he leaves. However, I want to tell you something I caught. What? Meredith wakes up twice. However, I want to tell you something I caught. What? Meredith wakes up twice. Oh really? She wakes up at four minutes and 38 seconds when Robert California walks in and then she wakes up again at five minutes and 27 seconds when he yells her name.
是的，他们是留下来的人。所以他说，我要你们所有人都来头脑风暴出具有创新性的颠覆性点子。对，不要害怕搞得有点古怪。然后他在离开前大喊着叫醒了梅雷迪思。不过，我要告诉你一件我注意到的事。什么？梅雷迪思醒了两次。不过，我要告诉你一件我注意到的事。什么？梅雷迪思醒了两次。哦真的吗？她在四分38秒罗伯特·加利福尼亚走进来时醒了一次，然后在五分27秒他喊她名字时又醒了一次。
Well, Robert's call to action is gonna really get Kevin's brain going. We see him, he has a marker duct tape to a stapler. Yes, it's his stapler marker. But it doesn't go well. He ends up crossing it off his list of ideas. Well, that list is real special. We had a fan question from Macie T. In Alberta, who said, Kevin's list cracks me up. Does number three say marker phone and how is that different from phone marker which is number four? And what on earth could human lady mean? Please tell me you have more information. Well I looked it up in the script and here's what it said. It said his ideas were stapler phone, marker phone, phone marker, stairs man, and human lady cheese.
好吧，罗伯特发布的任务召唤真的让凯文的大脑运转起来了。我们看到他，他把一支马克笔用胶带粘在订书机上。是的，那是他的“订书机马克笔”。但进展并不顺利。他最后把这个从他的创意清单上划掉了。好吧，那份清单真的很特别。我们收到了来自艾伯塔省的梅西·T的粉丝提问，她说，凯文的清单让我笑死。第三条是不是写着“马克笔手机”，这和第四条的“手机马克笔”有什么区别？“人类女士”到底是个什么鬼？求求你告诉我你知道更多信息。好吧，我在剧本里查了一下，上面是这么写的。上面说他的点子是：订书机手机、马克笔手机、手机马克笔、楼梯男，还有人类女士奶酪。
Yeah, because you can see the sea, but you don't know what it stands for. Yes, Macy thought maybe it's chair, a human lady that's also a chair. Apparently it's a combination of a human lady and cheese is what he's thinking. And how does that help you sell paper? I don't know, but when I think of a human lady and cheese,
是的，因为你能看到那个C字母，但你不知道它代表什么。是的，梅西觉得也许那是椅子，一个同时也是椅子的“人类女士”。显然这是在想“人类女士”和“奶酪”的结合体。这怎么能帮你卖纸呢？我不知道，但每当我想到“人类女士和奶酪”时，
I do think of you, Ange. Really? Well, you love cheese and you're a human lady. I am. So yeah. That is a combo that works for you. And you know what? Josh is kind of a stairsman.
我就会想到你，安吉。真的吗？好吧，你喜欢奶酪，而且你是一位人类女士。我是。所以，是的。这是一个对你来说行得通的组合。你知道吗？乔希有点像个楼梯男。
He loves a good watch house. He does, Cliff. I guess as a couple, we're a repersented on this list. Congratulations. Thank you. Human Lady cheese and stairsman should have been part of our wedding. If Kevin would have written our wedding vows, oh my gosh, because you imagine.
他很喜欢看别人走楼梯。他确实喜欢，克利夫。我猜作为夫妻，我们在单子上都有代表。恭喜。谢谢。人类女士奶酪和楼梯男本来应该成为我们婚礼的一部分。如果凯文来给我们写婚礼誓词的话，天哪，你能想象吗？
I cannot. Well, Andy is gosh, because you imagine I cannot. Well, Andy is super excited because the bus has arrived at Gettysburg. As you said, everyone's still watching the movie, which doesn't track. And Darryl wants them to know that he has source code for the ride back. I watched source code. I was going to say, did you watch source code? I did. I did not.
我简直不敢想象。好吧，安迪是……天哪，你能想象吗？我简直不敢想象。好吧，安迪超级兴奋，因为大巴已经抵达葛底斯堡了。正如你所说，大家还在看那部电影，这剧情完全不合逻辑。而且达里尔想让他们知道，他有返程看的电影《源代码》。我看了《源代码》。我本想说，你看过《源代码》吗？我看过。我没看。
Guess what? What? That one's only 90 minutes long. Uh-oh. It's even shorter. It has? That one's only 90 minutes long. Uh-oh. It's even shorter. It has a 92% on Rotten Tomatoes, and I'm gonna say, Darryl has great taste in movies.
你猜怎么着？什么？那部片子只有90分钟长。噢噢。它更短。它在烂番茄上有92%的好评率，我要说，达里尔的电影品味真棒。
I really liked this. This movie opens like in the middle of the movie, which is so fun. That's cool. Jake Gyllenhaal wakes up on a train. Okay. Doesn't know who he is. Eight minutes later, the train blows up.
我真的很喜欢这部电影。这部电影开场就像是在电影正中间，太好玩了。这很酷。杰克·吉伦哈尔在一辆火车上醒来。好的。不知道他是谁。八分钟后，火车爆炸了。
Ah! And then all of a sudden, he is like in this little like military pod thing and that woman comes on the screen and she's like, focus, focus. What did you see on the train? What did you see? I'm sending you back in. You have to figure out who's the bomb or on the train. We need to know because he's gonna bomb something else next
啊！然后突然之间，他就像是在这个类似军事舱的东西里，那个女人出现在屏幕上，她说：“专注，专注。你在火车上看到了什么？你看到了什么？我把你送回去。你必须找出火车上的炸弹客是谁。我们需要知道，因为他接下来还要炸别的东西。”
Sending him back in what is he as he's toggling through time? He's like going into the body of one of the train passengers What and then he has eight minutes to figure out who the bomber is and that's the movie and you have a problem with game of thrones What do you mean? You're like, I don't want to learn dragon names in blah, blah. So different. These are two totally different kinds of movies. How do you go into a human body? And like, how do you, what are these rules of physics? I'm having to learn to make this movie. Listen, I guess I love fantasy physics. I guess you do. Sass from you. My gosh. Hello.
把他送回去，当他在时间线里穿梭时他在做什么？他就像是进入了其中一个火车乘客的身体里，然后他有八分钟的时间找出炸弹客是谁，这就是整部电影。而你对《权力的游戏》有意见？这是什么意思？你当时说：“我才不想去记什么龙的名字呢，巴拉巴拉。”这完全不同。这是两种完全不同的电影。你怎么能进入别人的人体里？还有，这些物理规则到底是什么？为了看懂这部电影我不得不去学这些。听着，我猜我就是喜欢奇幻物理学。我想你确实是。你还挺会顶嘴。天哪。你好。
Speaking of Sass, Macy T and Alberta has maybe some mini Sass. Let's hear it, Macy. Macy says it has always bothered me that when they arrive at Gettysburg, it looks like it's evening. There are long shadows and the orange sunlight hitting the side of their faces and the bus. But then when they get off the bus, it looks like normal daytime.
说到顶嘴，艾伯塔省的梅西·T可能也有点小意见。我们来听听，梅西。梅西说：一直让我感到困扰的是，当他们到达葛底斯堡时，看起来像是傍晚。有长长的影子，还有橙色的阳光照在他们脸的侧面和大巴上。但接着当他们下车时，看起来就像是正常的白天。
Was the arrival filmed in the evening and how many days did it take to film all the Gettysburg parts? Macy is paying attention. That's for sure. Well, according to Steve Burgess, we shot two days at Woodley Park and Steve said, unfortunately, sometimes we had to shoot out of order. And so the shadows do not match. And he said that this made Matt's own crazy, but we didn't have any choice.
到达的场景是在傍晚拍摄的吗？拍摄所有的葛底斯堡部分一共花了几天时间？梅西真的很留心细节。那是肯定的。好吧，根据史蒂夫·伯吉斯的说法，我们在伍德利公园拍摄了两天，史蒂夫说，不幸的是，有时我们不得不颠倒顺序拍摄。所以影子根本对不上。他说这把马特快逼疯了，但我们别无选择。
This is how we had to do it. May see Matt's own would have talked your ear off about this. That's right. I thought that was a really good catch. I do too. I do too. Well, as the group is approaching the visitor center, Andy blocks them because he's like, hey, we're not tourists.
我们只能这么做。梅西，马特绝对会拉着你喋喋不休地抱怨这个。没错。我觉得这个细节抓得真好。我也这么觉得。我也这么觉得。好吧，当大家走向游客中心时，安迪把他们拦了下来，因为他说：“嘿，我们不是游客。
We are going to do the Andy Bernard tour. Oh, no. Yeah. Yeah. Well, when Andy starts his tour, Dwight is in the background and he is kind of schooling Aaron on the Battle of Shrute Farms, which he again says the history books have ignored. Right. You should see some of these letters says the history books have ignored. Right. You should see some of these letters that the soldiers wrote about their time there.
我们要进行的是安迪·伯纳德专属导览。”哦，不。好吧。好吧，当安迪开始他的导览时，德怀特在背景里，他正在向艾琳灌输关于舒鲁普农场战役的知识，他再次声称历史书忽视了这场战役。没错。你应该看看其中一些信件……历史书忽视了这场战役。没错。你应该看看士兵们写下的关于他们在那里的经历的信件。
And once again, it is the northernmost battle of the Civil War. Well, you know, when Dwight was telling Aaron, she should read some of the letters from the soldiers. This made me think about a time where I was in a museum and they would have letters from long ago displayed in glass cases And you could read like what people were doing at the time So I looked online and the New York State Library in Commemoration of the 150th anniversary of two major civil war battles including Gettysburg and Vicksburg
而且，这再次强调了它是内战最北端的战役。嗯，你知道的，当德怀特告诉艾琳她应该读读士兵们的一些信件时，这让我想起了我有一次在一个博物馆里，那里在玻璃柜里陈列着很久以前的信件，你可以读到当时的人们都在做些什么。所以我上网查了查，纽约州立图书馆为了纪念包括葛底斯堡和维克斯堡在内的两场美国内战重大战役150周年，
Digitized some of the letters from the soldiers and put them on their website. Oh wow! Yeah, so you don't have to go to a museum to see some of these. You can go on their website. I'll put it in stories. I found them very fascinating. I want to read one. Okay. This is from Calvin A. Haynes, who served as a sergeant in the 125th New York Infantry. He was raised in Troy, New York, and he has written a letter to his wife about the Battle of Gettysburg. July 19th, 1863. Dear wife.
将士兵们的一些信件数字化并放到了他们的网站上。哦，哇！是的，所以你不需要去博物馆就能看到这些信件。你可以直接上他们的网站。我会把它发到快拍里。我觉得它们非常迷人。我想读一封。好的。这是由加尔文·A·海恩斯写的一封信，他曾是纽约步兵第125团的一名中士。他在纽约州特洛伊长大，他写了一封信给他的妻子，讲的是葛底斯堡战役。1863年7月19日。亲爱的妻子。
Sorry. It's wait for the first line. Not having heard from you in a great while, I did not know, but what you would like to hear, whether I am dead or alive. Oh, no, something is happening in the smear. I know, very clear. Just the beginning, opening, beginning, made me think of that SNL sketch. Dear Lydia, where he's writing to. Oh my gosh, it's so good.
抱歉。等一下第一行。由于很久没有收到你的信了，我不知道你是想听到我活着还是死去的消……哦，不，这个字迹有点模糊。我知道，非常清晰。仅仅是开头，开场，开头，让我想起了那个周六夜现场的小品。亲爱的莉迪亚，他写信的对象是……哦天哪，太搞笑了。
Okay. Anyway, Calvin goes on to say, I am enjoying good health at present. We have had an awful march in a terrible battle. A great many of our boys were killed or wounded, but I escaped without a scratch. It is a miracle that we were not all killed or wounded. We were in the thickest of the fight, making a charge on the ribs.
好的。不管怎样，加尔文接着说：我目前身体健康。我们经历了一场艰苦的行军和一场可怕的战役。我们的许多小伙子阵亡或受伤，但我毫发无伤地逃过一劫。我们没有全部阵亡或受伤简直是个奇迹。我们身处战斗最激烈的地方，向暗堡发起冲锋。
A half a mile through a fire of grape and canister. Our regiment lost a hundred men in ten minutes. Our company lost eight and fourteen were wounded. Stephen Hunt was wounded in the hip. I have not seen him since he fell. Stephen was a good soldier full of his fun and we miss him. This has been the hardest campaign the Army of the Potomac ever had. The second in the afternoon was the Army of the Potomac ever had. The second in the afternoon was the bloodiest part of the battle. At 2pm they opened on us with over a hundred cannon. We lay flat on our faces for two hours. The air was filled with shell bursting in every direction. The battery that lay in front of us had 55 horses
在葡萄弹和榴霰弹的火海中冲了半英里。我们团在十分钟内损失了一百人。我们连损失了八人，十四人受伤。斯蒂芬·亨特臀部受伤。自从他倒下后我就没再见过他。斯蒂芬是个好士兵，总是充满了乐趣，我们都很想念他。这是波托马克军团经历过的最艰苦的战役。下午两点是……波托马克军团经历过的最艰苦的战役。下午两点是这场战役最血腥的部分。下午两点，他们用一百多门大炮向我们开火。我们在地上趴了两个小时。空气中弥漫着四处炸裂的炮弹。挡在我们正前方的炮连有55匹战马
and 80 men killed. That night and the next day, the rebels retreated, leaving their dead and wounded on the field. I went over the field, such a sight I never wish to see again. Every conceivable wound that can be thought of was there. There were so many wounded that it was impossible to attend to all of them. Some of them lay 48 hours in drenching rain. It is beyond the power of me to describe a battlefield. Wow. Isn't that powerful? I mean, wow. Yeah.
和80名士兵阵亡。那天晚上和第二天，叛军撤退了，把他们的死伤者丢在了战场上。我去战场上转了转，那样的景象我希望再也不要看到了。你能想到的每一种可怕的伤情都在那里。伤员实在太多了，根本不可能照顾到所有人。有些人躺在倾盆大雨中长达48小时。我已经无力描述战场是什么样了。哇。是不是很有冲击力？我的意思是，哇。是的。
There are more letters. And a common theme in all the letters is what a horrible, horrible battle. There were so many losses that on the Gettysburg field. Thank you for reading that letter, Angela. You now, I am reading the graphic novel of the Diary of Anne Frank. And these letters and diaries of people recounting their experiences during these times of war, I think it is so important for us to read and know these things. Thank you for reading that letter.
还有更多的信件。所有信件中一个共同的主题就是这是一场多么可怕、多么可怕的战役。葛底斯堡战场上有太多的死伤。谢谢你朗读那封信，安吉拉。你知道吗，我正在读《安妮日记》的图像小说。这些经历过战争时期的人们记录他们经历的信件和日记，我认为对我们来说去阅读并了解这些事情是如此重要。谢谢你读了那封信。
Yes, and I mean, you know, that was written July 19th of 1863. I really hope wife wrote back. I do too, because I mean, my gosh. I hope wife received the letter and they were able to find each other and all of that madness. Well, lady, on that note, I think we should take a break. And when we come back, we're going to hear from all of Robert California's free thinkers in the conference room. They are really bringing their A-game of ideas sort of. All right, we are back and Ryan is gonna go first. He's got a presentation for Robert and you know what it is? Raw fish. Lady, we laughed so hard at raw fish.
是的，我的意思是，你知道的，那是1863年7月19日写的。我真的很希望他的妻子回信了。我也这么希望，因为，天哪。我希望妻子收到了信，他们能够重聚，经历了所有这些疯狂的事后。好吧，女士，基于此，我想我们该休息一下了。等我们回来后，我们将听到会议室里所有罗伯特·加利福尼亚的自由思想者们的发言。他们真的是拿出了最高水平的点子……差不多吧。好的，我们回来了，瑞恩要第一个发言。他有一个方案要呈献给罗伯特，你知道是什么吗？生鱼。女士，我们被生鱼笑惨了。
We could not pull it back. There was the way he said it. I wanted a solicitor to it. I saw Mindy break. I saw her break. She has the, like, she has the silliest smile in her face through his whole presentation. You know when we talked about Mike Tibbitts, is like a trigger? Raw fish. Raw fish. The disgusting food from Japan that Americans would never want to eat. Now, we can't get enough of it. From movie stars to construction workers, sushi is what's for dinner.
我们简直笑得停不下来。他说话那个语气。我想去推销它。我看到敏迪笑场了。我看到她笑了。在她做整个方案汇报时，她脸上带着最傻气的微笑。你知道当我们谈到迈克·蒂比茨时，就像是个触发点吗？生鱼。生鱼。日本人那种恶心的食物，美国人本来是绝对不想吃的。现在，我们对它爱不释手。从电影明星到建筑工人，寿司成了晚餐的首选。
Ah, lady, I videotaped this speech and I sent it to BJ because I was like, do you remember this BJ, raw fish? Also, it's like Ryan thinks he's one of those voice actors that does the trailers for movies like in a world where there's raw fish. Yes. Well, Ryan's idea is that he wants to make origami the sushi of paper. Yeah. He thinks that it could sweep the nation in the same way that sushi did. I was so tickled by all of Robert California's responses. Yes.
啊，女士，我把这段演讲录了下来并发送给了BJ，因为我当时说：“你还记得这个吗，BJ，生鱼？”而且，这感觉就像瑞恩觉得自己是个电影预告片的配音演员，比如“在一个充满生鱼的世界里……”是的。好吧，瑞恩的点子是，他想把折纸变成纸业中的寿司。对。他认为这能以寿司风靡全国的方式席卷整个国家。我被罗伯特·加利福尼亚的所有反应逗得乐不可支。对。
The way he shoots someone's idea down is so hilarious. And this is what he said. I recorded them. This is what he says to Ryan. This idea hasn't gripped me. What else did you come up with? Well, I had to memorize the presentation, Robert, and it took a long time to build the swan, so that was bad.
他拒绝别人想法的方式太搞笑了。这就是他说的话。我都录下来了。他是这么对瑞安说的：“这个想法没吸引我。你还想出了什么？”“好吧，罗伯特，我得把演讲背下来，而且搭那个天鹅花了很长时间，所以这太糟糕了。”
That was very much to the point. So now Stanley's gonna present his idea. It's called paper, P-A-P-Y-R. It's pink, scented, and silky soft. It's paper for women. Yeah. Now you can watch the game and she can write a letter to her sister. This is what Robert said to that pitch.
这真是切中要害。现在斯坦利要展示他的想法了。它叫纸，P-A-P-Y-R。它是粉红色的，带香味的，而且丝滑柔软。这是专为女性设计的纸。是的。现在你可以看比赛，而她可以给她姐姐写信。这就是罗伯特对这个推销的评价。
The situation you described returning home to a wife complaining about her paper being too masculine is not one of it for a million. The situation you described. Oh my gosh. that cracked me up. Finally, Pam is going to get up. She starts speaking and then she says, you know what, I'm already not feeling it. Yeah. She wanted to put little coupons at the back of a test booklet, you know, like when you're
你描述的这种情况——回到家面对妻子抱怨她的纸太男性化——并不是百万里挑一的情况。你描述的这种情况。哦天哪。这让我笑疯了。最后，潘要站起来了。她开始发言，然后她说：“你知道吗，我其实已经没有这种感觉了。”是的。她想在测试手册的背面放一些小优惠券，你知道的，就像你在
in school and then she's like, you know, unless you're responding to it, he goes, I am not. Yeah, exactly. The person who's gonna get Robert's attention is Kevin. Yeah. He starts talking about cookie placement in the vending machine. Yeah. Robert isn't intrigued.
学校里那样，然后她接着说：“你知道的，除非你在回应它，”他说：“我没有。”没错。能引起罗伯特注意的人是凯文。是的。他开始谈论自动售货机里的饼干摆放位置。是的。罗伯特并不感兴趣。
He translates what Kevin has said into being, Oh, I have it. Oh, please. Yeah. So basically, Kevin's like, why put a cookie that you really want people to eat in A1? When your eyes naturally go to D4? Yeah.
他把凯文的话翻译成：“哦，我明白了。哦，拜托。”是的。所以基本上，凯文的意思是：为什么要把人们真正想吃的饼干放在A1位置？当你的视线自然而然会落到D4？是的。
And Robert's like, huh, cookie placement. Who else agrees with Kevin that we're wasting facilities, manpower, on our own, underselling products when we should be pushing our top performers? Hmm. Everyone raises their hand and they're all collectively like, what the hell just happened. Kevin continues. He says another thing about oatmeal cookies. Who even wants them? I mean, I've seen Toby eat like one once, but other than that, Robert says interesting. So what is Dunder Mifflin's oatmeal cookie? What is the product that no one wants? Stanley chimes in. How about that two-hole punch letter? Only the lawyers want that punch at
罗伯特说：“哦？饼干的摆放位置。还有谁同意凯文的看法，即我们在自己身上浪费了设施和人力，在应该推销顶尖产品的时候却在低价销售产品？”嗯。所有人都举起了手，他们集体的心情是：刚才到底发生了什么鬼。凯文继续说道。他又说了一句关于燕麦饼干的话。谁会想要这玩意儿？我的意思是，我曾看见托比吃过大概一次，但除此之外——罗伯特说：“很有意思。那么，邓德·米夫林的燕麦饼干是什么？哪个产品是没人想要的？”斯坦利插话道。“那个双孔打孔信纸怎么样？只有律师才在顶部用那种打孔，而且他们用的是法律用纸。”罗伯特说：“这就是燕麦饼干。太棒了，凯文。太棒了！”这个副线情节本会继续下去。删减片段里有一个，我想让你们听听。问题是，对冲基金本质上是一场懦夫的游戏。你在对冲风险。我猜你看透了数字。有时候我真希望我能走你的路，戈文。花几年时间只生活在数字里。是的。我处理数字。
the top and they use legal. Robert goes, that's the oatmeal cookie. Fantastic, Kevin. Fantastic! This runner would have continued. There was one in deleted scenes, and I want you to hear it. The problem is the hedge fund is essentially a coward's game. You're hedging your bets. I suppose you see right through the numbers. Sometimes I wish I'd taken your road, Govin. Just taken a few years to just live in the numbers. Yeah. I do the numbers.
哦天哪。哦天哪。哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，向大家分享一些信息，但德怀特继续喋喋不休地讲述这场朱特农场的战役。正是在那个时候，一个年轻女孩把盖布错认成了林肯。天哪，在删减片段里，这是一个更大的副线情节。一路上好几次都有小孩拦下他。这太棒了。它最终高潮于这个人要求合影，但大家一整天都在看着他、指指点点并窃窃私语。
Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, share some information with the group, but Dwight continues to go on about this battle of shrewt farms. And that is when a young girl is going to mistake Gabe for Lincoln. Lady, this was such a bigger runner in the deleted scenes. Multiple times kids are stopping him along the way. That's great. It finally culminates to this person asking for a photo, but people are like looking at him and pointing in whispering for the whole day.
哦，天哪。哦，天哪。哦……分享一些信息给团队，但德怀特继续喋喋不休地讲着这个关于施鲁特农场的大战。就在那时，一个小女孩把盖布误认成了林肯。女士，这在删减片段里真的是个很大的支线。孩子们一路上多次拦住他。太棒了。最后以这个人要求合影告终，但一整天人们都在看着他、指指点点并窃窃私语。
I looked it up to see if Zach Woods had ever played Lincoln before. And according to his IMDB, I couldn't find anything. I thought, oh, maybe on drunk history. Yeah. Or I don't know some other parody somewhere. No, we were the ones who capitalized on his Lincoln look alike ability. I know we really wanted to ask Zach about this. Well, let's add that to the list of things we
我查了一下扎克·伍兹以前是否扮演过林肯。根据他的IMDB，我什么也没找到。我想，哦，也许是在《醉史》里吧。是的。或者我不知道别的什么恶搞节目里。不，是我们利用了他长得像林肯的能力。我知道我们真的很想问扎克这件事。好吧，把它加到我们
want to ask Zach. We had a fan question from Eli E and Denver, Colorado, who said how much of Gabe's speech as Lincoln was scripted. Well, Eli, it was all scripted, but it was massively reordered. Originally, the bulk of his speech was the tag at the end of the episode, but we reordered a lot of this episode in editing. Scenes got moved around, and because of this, you're going to see, for example, at 13 minutes and 29 seconds, Gabe is standing by a tree with the rest of the group while he's simultaneously giving a speech as Lincoln.
想问扎克的清单上吧。我们收到了来自科罗拉多州丹佛市的伊莱·E的一位粉丝提问，他说盖布作为林肯的演讲有多少是按剧本演的。好吧，伊莱，全都是按剧本演的，但经过了大规模的重新排序。原本，他演讲的大部分内容是剧集末尾的彩蛋，但我们在剪辑中重新排序了这集的很多内容。场景被搬来搬去，正因如此，你会看到，例如在13分29秒时，盖布正和其余的人一起站在一棵树旁，而他同时还在发表林肯的演讲。
So I guess in answer to your question, it was all scripted. At this point, Andy is going to try to get people to go on a very long walk to Spangler Spring, but people are hungry. You know, they're not really up for it. They're tired. I looked up Spangler Spring and it's a pretty cool part of the park. You know, they could do worse than to follow Andy there. He should have had food with him.
所以我想回答你的问题，全都是按剧本演的。此时，安迪正试图让大家去进行一次很长的散步，走到斯潘格勒泉，但大家都很饿。你知道的，他们其实不太想去。他们累了。我查了一下斯潘格勒泉，那是公园里一个挺酷的地方。你知道的，跟着安迪去那里，总比什么都不做好。他本该随身带点食物的。
He locked all the food and everything back in the bus. Yeah. Oscar has located an archivist for the Gettysburg Museum. And it turns out this fella knows a little something about troop farms. Yes, he has heard of it. The archivist was played by Weston Nathanson. You might also recognize him from the Mindy Project, Law and Order, Boston Legal with James Bader, and most recently Superstore. He's going to put in a documentary video that explains what really happened at Shrute Farms. There was no battle.
他把所有的食物和其他东西都锁回大巴里了。是的。奥斯卡找到了一位葛底斯堡博物馆的档案管理员。结果这个人对朱特农场略知一二。是的，他听说过。这位档案管理员由韦斯顿·纳森森饰演。你可能也会从《明迪烦事多》、《法律与秩序》、《波士顿法律》（与詹姆斯·斯派德合作）以及最近的《超级商店》中认出他。他将放映一段纪录片视频，解释朱特农场究竟发生了什么。根本没有什么战役。
No. It was a refuge for artists, for dandies and dreamers. Yeah. They put on plays and they sang tender ballads. They danced in the moonlight. It was basically an underground railroad for the fabulous. Oscar agrees there should have been a monument to this. We got a lot of mail about this documentary from Brandon R. and Illinois and Jessica N. and Rochester, New York.
没有。这里是艺术家、花花公子和梦想家的避难所。是的。他们上演戏剧，唱着温柔的情歌。他们在月光下跳舞。这基本上是为那些传奇人物准备的地下铁路。奥斯卡同意这里应该立一座纪念碑。我们收到了很多关于这部纪录片的邮件，来自伊利诺伊州的布兰登·R和纽约州罗切斯特市的杰西卡·N。
Can you please tell us how all the wonderful photos were made for the Battle of Shrute Farms mini documentary? I must know who played all of the artistic and sensitive members of the group. Were they crew members? These little details make me so happy. Well, I spied Matt's own. Mm-hmm. And one of our writers, Steve Healy. Yes. So, Matt's own is in the center of that big photo.
请告诉我们，为了《朱特农场之战》这部迷你纪录片，那些精彩的照片都是怎么拍摄的吗？我必须知道是谁扮演了这群艺术而敏感的成员。他们是剧组成员吗？这些小细节让我太高兴了。好吧，我看到了马特·索恩。嗯哼。还有我们的编剧之一，史蒂夫·希利。是的。所以，马特·索恩就在那张大照片的正中央。
And Steve Healy is on the right playing the flute. Mm-hmm. He's also in shirtless. Yeah, and I was going to say, pumping his muscles in that picture. He's the one shirtless. Yeah, I was gonna say pumping his muscles down that picture. He's the one on the left. But the rest of the people were background actors. We took all of these photos on a green screen
而史蒂夫·希利在右边吹长笛。嗯哼。他当时还光着膀子。是的，我本来想说，那张照片里他正在展示肌肉。光着膀子的是他。是的，我本来想说，那张照片里他在展示肌肉。他就是左边那个。但其他人都是背景演员。我们在绿幕前拍摄了所有这些照片，
over on our warehouse set. And Steve Burgess said, this was a major production. You know, Jenny O'Keefe, who was our second ID, she wrote out a 10-page document breakdown that detailed every shot, every photo that had to be taken. There was a special wardrobe fitting and hair and makeup tests with all of the people in the photos. Her documents said, quote, LeVernin Kim will add or take away hair as needed. Add or take away hair as needed. Add or take away.
就在我们的仓库布景里。史蒂夫·伯格斯说，这是一场重大制作。你知道的，我们的第二副导演珍妮·奥基夫写了一份长达10页的文件细目，详细列出了每一个镜头、每一张必须拍摄的照片。所有照片中的人物都进行了专门的服装试穿以及发型和化妆测试。她的文件上写着：“引述，拉文和金将根据需要增加或减少头发。根据需要增加或减少头发。增加或减少。”
So, you know, if hair had to be added, that would be LeVern and makeup. But if it had to be taken away, like a shaver, a haircut, that would be Kim. But we also brought in two additional makeup artists in order to get everybody ready. The last photo they took was the one with Matt Sone, and this was noted in Jenny's document because he was directing in the other photos. So we were gonna try to take as many photos as possible and throw him in at the end. Matt had also grown a very extensive beard.
所以，你知道，如果需要增加头发，那将由拉文和化妆负责。但如果需要减少，比如用剃须刀、剪个发，那就归金负责。但我们还请来了两位额外的化妆师，以便让每个人都准备就绪。他们拍的最后一张照片是马特·索恩的那张，这在珍妮的文件中有所标注，因为他在拍其他照片时一直在担任导演。所以我们打算尽可能多拍些照片，最后把他塞进去。马特当时还留了一把非常浓密的胡子。
Yes, which probably made him perfect for Civil War error photography. Yes. Also, our writer Owen Ellison is the narrator of this film, and Dave Rogers is the voice of Melvin Fyfergeris. I heard him right away. Me too.
是的，这可能使他非常适合拍摄南北战争时期的照片。是的。此外，我们的编剧欧文·埃利森是这部电影的旁白，戴夫·罗杰斯是梅尔维尔·菲费格里斯的配音。我一下子就听出来了。我也是。
Listen, one of the things I wanted to point out earlier, and I just didn't get it in. That's what she said. This is a very ridiculous, probably background catch, but I could not unsee it once I had seen it. Back at the beginning of the episode, Dwight has a talking head, and I'm telling you, Rain had clearly just had a haircut. And talking about all of these haircuts, yeah, it made me think of it.
听着，有一件事我之前就想指出来，但一直没机会。这就是她说的。这是一个非常荒谬的、可能是背景里的彩眼，但我一旦看到了就挥之不去。回到这集的开头，德怀特有一个面对镜头的独白，我跟你说，雷恩显然刚理过发。说到所有这些发型，是的，这让我想到了它。
If you start the episode at two minutes, 53 seconds, he has the shortest little bangs in his little zipper part. They don't even make it like just a few little inches on his forehead. Wow. Yeah. Someone had a haircut. Well, someone wrote in and said that they thought rain looked really fit in this episode.
如果你从2分53秒开始看这一集，他那小小的齐刘海在他那个小小的闪电分缝里是最短的。它们甚至都没占到他额头上的几英寸长。哇。是的。有人理发了。好吧，有人写信说他们觉得雷恩在这集里看起来状态非常好。
Oh. And moving forward, he continues to look very fit. I wonder if the haircut and the fitness were for a role. Oh, moving forward, he continues to look very fit. I wonder if the haircut and the fitness were for a role. Oh, yeah. Maybe so. I'm going to look it up for next week. Yeah. Robert and Kevin are spending more time together.
哦。而且接下来，他看起来一直状态非常好。我想知道这个发型和好身材是不是为了某个角色。哦，接下来，他看起来一直状态非常好。我想知道这个发型和好身材是不是为了某个角色。哦，是的。也许吧。我下周查查看。是的。罗伯特和凯文花越来越多的时间在一起。
We're in the break room. And Kevin is telling Robert you can never trust a cookie with a woman's name. Lorna Dune, Madeline, Pacon Sandy, or Pican Sandy depending on where you live. They'll just break your heart. Ryan has had it, you guys. He has had it with Kevin being sort of like the genius of the office. He's going to set him up. He comes in the break room and he's like, hey, I want to pitch one of my ideas. It's called the Big Mac idea. And Kevin is instantly annoyed. He's like, no, no, no, that's my idea and you know it. The Big Mac idea is so disgusting.
我们在休息室里。凯文正在告诉罗伯特，你永远不能相信一个用女人名字命名的饼干。洛娜·多恩饼干、玛德琳蛋糕、佩坎桑迪饼干，或者根据你住的地方叫山核桃桑迪饼干。它们只会让你心碎。瑞安受够了，各位。他受够了凯文被当成办公室天才这种事。他要设计陷害他。他走进休息室，说道：“嘿，我想推销一个我的想法。它叫巨无霸想法。”凯文瞬间被惹恼了。他说：“不，不，不，那是我的想法，你知道的。”巨无霸想法太令人作呕了。
It's so gross. Basically, here's the Big Mac idea, which Kevin proudly says to Robert and Robert starts to see the writing on the wall here. Kevin says you get a Big Mac and each day, you get one every day for like a week. And each day you take out one ingredient. You set it aside. Yeah. And by the end of the week, you have a bonus Big Mac that you can reassemble. Yeah.
太恶心了。基本上，巨无霸想法是这样的：凯文自豪地对罗伯特说，罗伯特开始看出这里的苗头不对了。凯文说，你买一个巨无霸，然后每天吃一个，连续吃一个星期左右。每天你拿走一种配料。把它放在一边。是的。到周末的时候，你就得到了一个可以重新组装的额外巨无霸。是的。
I mean, is he scraping the cheese? I don't know. Off of these pickles. So I don't know. Disgusting. Also, what about the day where he eats the Big Mac with no bun? Well, people do that. Disgusting. Also, what about the day where he eats the big mac with no bun? Well, people do that.
我的意思是，他在刮奶酪吗？我不知道。从这些酸黄瓜上？所以我不知道。太恶心了。还有，他吃没有面包胚的巨无霸的那天怎么办？好吧，人们会那样做。太恶心了。还有，他吃没有面包胚的巨无霸的那天怎么办？好吧，人们会那样做。
Yeah. Yeah. But Kevin, but anyway, Robert just looks at him and goes, it was really just about the cookie all along, wasn't it? Yeah. Yeah. It turns out that Darryl and Jim did follow Andy. No one else came, though. everyone else is back at the bus.
是的。是的。但凯文，总之，罗伯特只是看着他，然后说：“这一切其实一直都是关于饼干的，对吧？”是的。是的。原来达里尔和吉姆确实跟着安迪走了。不过没有别人来。其他人都在大巴上。
I don't think they so much followed him as one of them to know that people are done, they're tired, they can't get in the bus, they can't get their food. Yeah. And, you know, Jim is being a little bit of a wiseass and Andy calls him out on it. Mm-hmm. I think in the biggest way that anyone has ever called him out on the show,
我觉得与其说他们是跟着他，不如说他们中的一个人想知道大家累了，走不动了，上不了大巴，吃不上饭。是的。而且，你知道的，吉姆有点在耍小聪明，安迪当面指出了这一点。嗯哼。我觉得这是这部剧里任何人对他的最大程度的当面指责，
and I think we should hear it. Okay. Yeah, sorry everybody else didn't come. I think they're just tired with holes in their shoes and they have dysentery. Even without an audience, you're just still at it. What are you talking about? Our office has a disease, and it goes by many names. Sarc has them. Snark. Wise cracks. You take things that people care about
我觉得我们应该听听看。好的。是的，很抱歉其他人没有来。我想他们只是累了，鞋底都磨破了，还得了痢疾。即使没有观众，你还是这副德行。你在说什么？我们办公室有一种病，它有很多名字。萨克病有。讽刺。俏皮话。你把别人在乎的事情
and you make them feel lame about it with your jokes. That's what you did with this trip. I mean, he called it out, didn't he? I have so many things I'm not saying. Oh no, Angela, I have thought for a long time that Jim has changed a little bit. And I don't like the Jim snark. He used to be an underdog that you were rooting for.
拿来用你的笑话让他们觉得很无趣。这就是你对这次旅行所做的事。我的意思是，他当面指出来了，不是吗？我有太多想说却没说的话。哦不，安吉拉，我一直觉得吉姆有一点变了。而且我不喜欢吉姆的这种讽刺。他过去是一个你支持的底层小人物。
Yeah. And now he's too cool for school. A little bit, you know? And it's a little bit of like a superiority thing. And it's this subtle shift that I have not loved in the character I have to say. For season eight. It kind of starting in season seven into season eight. And it's almost like when he gets the girl. And then Pam participates in it sometimes too. And it's an aspect of them. And they're journey that I have not loved. Super love.
是的。而现在他显得高人一等、不可一世。有点那种感觉，你知道吗？这有点像是一种优越感。而且这种微妙的转变是我一直不太喜欢的，对于这个角色，我必须得说。从第八季开始。有点从第七季开始一直延续到第八季。这就好像当他追到女孩的时候。然后潘有时也会参与其中。这是他们以及他们的一段心路历程中我不太喜欢的一个方面。超级不喜欢。
The two cool for school journey. Yeah. Well, I thought Andy really called him out and was so honest. Yes. You know? And Jim's response is, you know, he doesn't apologize. Yeah. But he does say, you know what?
那种高人一等的心路历程。是的。嗯，我觉得安迪真的当面指出了这一点，而且非常坦诚。是的。你知道吗？而吉姆的回应是，你知道的，他并没有道歉。是的。但他确实说：“你知道吗？
You're parallel between war and business. It just doesn't really hold up. This is a simple paper company, and you're the manager, and people like you, and you don't need to prove yourself. So he's saying some nice things. Yeah. And he says, look, I'm even wearing a very pink hat that I think says something sexual on it, maybe.
你把战争和商业做类比。这根本站不住脚。这只是一家简单的造纸公司，而你是经理，大家都很喜欢你，你不需要证明自己。”所以他说了一些好听的话。是的。他说：“看，我甚至戴了一顶非常粉的帽子，我觉得上面可能写了什么带有性暗示的话。”
And I'm doing that for you. I'm wearing this ridiculous hat. I went on this adventure for you. And that really means something to Andy. And Daryl's like, yeah, man, I hate myself for wearing this hat, but I'm here with you. So I feel like Jim tried to give him a pep talk. He didn't really own his Ysass. That's right. And I did, unfortunately, look up what DM does GB means. So I know now. What does it mean? Well, what? Jim was that wrong. What?
“我这是为了你才这么做的。我戴着这顶荒谬的帽子。我为了你进行了这次冒险。”这对安迪来说意义重大。达里尔则说：“是啊，老兄，我恨死自己戴这顶帽子了，但我在这儿陪着你。”所以我觉得吉姆试图给他来一剂鸡汤。他并没有真正承认自己耍小聪明。没错。而且我居然还真的去查了DM的意思是什么GB是什么。所以我现在知道了。那是什么意思？嗯，什么？吉姆有那么错吗？什么？
According to Urban Dictionary, it means dirty milk does gangbang. I'm telling you my story. I thought that that was just like Jim being like, I mean, it feels like it could be something dirty. I didn't know. Well, that's what I found in Urban Dictionary. So sorry for that guys, but that's what they were walking around the whole day with on their heads. Well, that makes a second viewing of that
根据城市词典，它的意思是脏牛奶在搞群交。我跟你们讲我的故事。我还以为那是吉姆在装蒜，比如，我觉得这听起来可能有点色情。我根本不知道。好吧，这就是我在城市词典里找到的。所以为此向大家道歉，但这就是他们一整天戴在头上的东西。好吧，这让第二次观看那一集
episode. Have a new filter. We had a fan catch from Sabrina S and Queen's New York who said, you know, in this episode, they're outside and a number of times people talk about how really hot it is. But how can this be? This episode is two episodes before the Christmas episode, which means it's more like early to mid-December. Wouldn't it be freezing in Pennsylvania? Serena, this is such a good catch. I was very curious too. And remember how I said I found an early draft, like a table redraft, where Angela goes with them? Yeah. Also in that same script, it said, they toured the cemetery and it's getting extremely cold.
有了一个全新的滤镜。我们收到了来自纽约州皇后区萨布丽娜·S的粉丝抓包，她说，你知道的，在这集里，他们在室外，好几次人们都在谈论天气到底有多热。但这怎么可能呢？这一集是圣诞节那一集的前两集，这意味着它更像是12月初到中旬。彭州难道不应该天寒地冻吗？塞丽娜，这个抓包太棒了。我也很好奇。还记得我说过我找到了一份早期初稿，比如台词围读草案，里面安吉拉和他们一起去了吗？是的。同样是在那份剧本里写着，他们参观了墓地，而且天气变得极其寒冷。
Well, Garden Party, which was a few episodes ago, they're all complaining about how cold it is. Yes. There's a heat wave in December, I guess. But there was a whole storyline that the weather would be an obstacle for this Gettysburg tour. I guess when we got there and it was hot, the sun was just right up in the sky. There you go.
好吧，在《花园派对》这一集里，也就是几集前，大家都在抱怨天气有多冷。是的。我猜12月出现了一场热浪。但原本有一个整条故事线，讲的是天气会成为这次葛底斯堡之旅的一个阻碍。我猜当我们到达那里时天气很热，太阳就挂在天上。就是这样。
This episode does end with Gabe finishing his performance as Abe Lincoln. We had a fan catch from Rachel G in Pennsylvania who says, I don't even know if anyone else has mentioned this, but there's a connection between Gabe's speech and Michael's talking head in season two, Casino Knight. Michael says that the Lincoln assassination recently became funny again, and he makes the joke, I need to see this play like I need a hole in the head. And in this episode, he says, I need her, meaning Mary, like I need a hole in the head. And in this episode, he says, I need her, meaning Mary, like I need a hole in the head. Was this an intentional call back to Michael Scott or coincidence that
这一集的结尾是盖布完成了他作为亚伯拉罕·林肯的表演。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州雷切尔·G的粉丝抓包，她说，我甚至不知道有没有其他人提到过这一点，但盖布的演讲与迈克尔在第二季《赌场之夜》中的独白之间存在某种联系。迈克尔说林肯遇刺事件最近又变得好笑起来了，他还开玩笑说：“我看这个剧目的心情就像我需要脑门开个洞一样急切。”而在这一集中，他说：“我需要她，指的是玛丽，就像我需要脑门开个洞一样。”而在这一集中，他说：“我需要她，指的是玛丽，就像我需要脑门开个洞一样。”这究竟是向迈克尔·斯科特的有意致敬，还是编剧们开了同一个玩笑纯属巧合？
the writers made the same joke twice? Rachel, I'm going with coincidence, but I love love when people find these connections to earlier episodes because people know the show so well. They know the show so well, but I do think there's something to group mind. Sometimes when there's shared information in a room, it comes back around. It sure does. Well, there you have it, everybody. Getty's Burke. Yeah. I really wish we knew more of Daryl's movie choices because he has very good taste in films. Geno's a big fan of Daryl's movie choices.
雷切尔，我认为这纯属巧合，但我太喜欢、太喜欢人们发现这些与早期剧集的联系了，因为大家对这部剧太了解了。他们对这部剧太了解了，但我确实认为这其中存在某种集体潜意识。有时当房间里共享某些信息时，它就会再次浮现。确实如此。好吧，大家听到了吧，葛底斯堡。是的。我真的很想多了解一些达里尔的电影选择，因为他在电影方面很有品味。吉诺也是达里尔电影选择的超级粉丝。
I'd like to say I also recently watched The Inside Man, which stars Clive Owen and Denzel Washington and Jody Foster, and it was excellent, and I think it would be on Daryl's list. I haven't seen any of these movies. Well, you're not icing your broken shoulder all the time. I have a list for the summer, I guess. Well, big thanks to Steve Burgess and Matt Flynn
我想说我也刚看了《局内人》，主演是克里夫·欧文、丹泽尔·华盛顿和朱迪·福斯特，非常棒，我觉得它应该在达里尔的片单上。我这些电影都没看过。好吧，又不是你在随时用冰块敷受伤的肩膀。我想我有一份夏日看片清单吧。好吧，非常感谢史蒂夫·伯格斯和马特·弗林
for all of your great insider info. And Michael Gallenberg for helping me find information once again, he's always so sweet. And you guys, for sending in your questions and comments, you're just the best. We'll see you next week. Bye. See you next week! Bye! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies! Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
提供所有精彩的内部消息。还有迈克尔·盖伦伯格再次帮我寻找信息，他总是那么贴心。还有你们，发来问题和评论，你们真的是最棒的。我们下周见。拜拜。下周见！拜拜！感谢收听《办公室女士》！《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。
Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keifer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Bratton. For at free versions of Office Ladies, go to stitur premium dot com. For a free one month trial of stitur premium use code office. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的高级制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是Jordan Duffy，我们的助理制作人是艾斯利·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问stitcherpremium.com。免费试用一个月stitcher premium，请使用优惠码office。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。